what's up believe nation I need your
help in picking the next top ten that
are coming out on the channel and this
is the video where you can leave your
requests
[Music]
so we've done hundreds of popped ends on
this channel hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds maybe thousands have to see how
many we've done for top-end
and that most of them now they're coming
from you guys from your feedback and
when you're leaving comments on
different videos we collect them we
start adding up
you know who's getting the most number
of votes and we're at the point where we
have two to three thousand more requests
that are in our backlog and I want to
make it easier for everybody to help
pick the next top ten so here's what
we're going to do this is the video that
we're going to pick the top tens from if
you have somebody that you would like to
vote for to see a next top 10 or top 10
volume to maybe volume three or beyond
leave it down the comments below and
what we're going to do is the ones that
have the most thumbs up the ones that
get voted up the most are going to be
the ones that we look at next for making
the top 10 on the channel and so instead
of leaving comments all over the
different videos on the channel this is
the single video where all the comments
will be aggregated this is the one that
we're paying attention to so leave the
comments down wherever you want to see a
next top ten on or volume two three four
five wherever we get to and if you see
ones that you like give it a thumbs up
give it a vote because those are going
to be the ones that rise up and we're
going to pick to do them next so thank
you for your support I'm super curious
to see how this challenge goes and I
look forward to seeing who you guys want
to see next in the top ten series
[Music]